[Música]
espero que disfruten este tema tanto
como nosotros disfrutamos de hacer
nuestra música pueden acompañar con las
palmas si así lo desean
[Música]
no sé muy bien cómo vamos a hacer no sé
muy bien si lo podremos ver con ideas
transformar y crecer cien diez años
saber quiénes vamos a hacer
es serán sociales son individuales habrá
más encuentros virtuales o contactos
reales tanta pantalla táctil tan como
tantos que asusta un te amo le ganará un
comentario me gusta no sé muy bien cómo
vamos
no sé voy de su madre
y en diez años
[Música]
pasemos a hablar
podemos elegir el ser sin madurar
entendemos que es mejor vivir de buen
humor la serendipia mantendrá vivo
nuestro año inunde yo no sé muy bien
cómo vamos a hacer no sé muy bien si no
podremos ver con ideas y crecer y es
necesario saber quién es
vamos a hacer lo haremos
basado en generar las energías
renovables en masa no pensar solamente
en uno mismo y considerarla en tierra
como un solo
bien cómo vamos a hacernos
y lo podremos ver con ideas transformar
y crecer
diez años a ver bien
y el arte y para qué será
será sólo un espejismo una banalidad
será una expresión de sentimientos o
será que la cantidad de ganará la
calidad
[Música]
vamos a hacer no sé si lo podremos ver
con ideas transformar y crecer y en 10
años saber qué vamos a hacer
vemos más humanos al menos lo suficiente
para cuidar al mundo equitativamente
dejar de pensar sólo en lo que conviene
y lograr ayudar a los que menos tienen
[Música]
si lo podemos ver con ideas transformar
y en diez años
vamos a ver
la competencia por la creación será
perjudicial nuestro ego de saltar
de frente a muerte
por todas las empresas que la propia
queridos
[Música]
sé muy bien si lo podremos ver con ideas
por mar
en diez años
[Música]
de la gente educación y calidad que
estudiaremos en un mundo que no para de
cambiar aprenderemos todo es lo mismo y
a la misma edad o seremos educados de
manera en igual
[Música]
y lo podremos ver con ideas transformar
en 10 años saber
sobre cómo vamos a gobernar no tengo
pista
seremos comunidad o individualista
no sé ni cómo
podemos ver por ideas transformar eso y
tres serían diez años
no construiremos nuestras
viviremos como dentro de los celulares
como nos informaremos de la realidad
usaremos que en el tiempo sin quemarte
la ansiedad
[Música]
y
en 10 años
sé muy bien cómo vamos
no sé muy bien si lo podremos ver con
ideas transformar
[Música]
a ver qué
no
no sé muy bien si lo podemos ver son
ideas transformar y crecer y en 10 años
[Música]
no sé muy bien si lo podremos ver con
idea transformada en la iglesia y en
diez años
no te voy
cómo vamos hacer
[Música]
y crecer en 10 años saber tiene vamos a
ver
[Aplausos]
y qué razones y me ha causado
[Música]
muchas gracias disfruten